if the u.s side insists on making a
visit the chinese side will take firm
and strong measures to safeguard our
sovereignty and territorial integrity
the u.s must assume full responsibility
for any severe consequence arising
thereof
china has warned that pelosi's expected
trip to taiwan would cross a red line
and keeps making threats about how they
will respond tonight we are learning new
details about what that could mean
a reporter for the global times which is
chinese state media suggested actually
shooting her plane down writing if u.s
fighter jets escort pelosi's plane into
taiwan it is invasion the people's
liberation army has the right to
forcibly dispel pelosi's plane and the
u.s fighter jets including firing
warning shots and making tactical
movement of obstruction if ineffective
then shoot them down
joining us now is morgan ortegas former
spokesperson for the department of state
and gordon chang gatestone institute
senior fellow and author of an amazing
book it's called the great u.s china
tech war i highly recommend it uh gordon
thanks for joining us here on set uh you
know an awful lot about what's going on
here what's your response to to this
blustering by china this very well may
not be bluster you know it's
inconceivable to us that the tla
people's liberation army would shoot
down pelosi's plane but you got to
remember at this very instant there were
four chinese warships in japanese
territorial water in the senkakus in the
east china sea their chinese troops deep
into indian controlled territory in
ladakh in the himalayas you know a few
weeks ago the chinese provoked a crisis
in the south china sea with the
philippines china is lashing out it
might be taiwan but it might be
someplace else this is an extremely
dangerous regime at this moment
uh morgan what what's i want to play
this clip from the white house because
the spokesperson was asked for a
response in what the white house thinks
about this listen to this i want to get
your response
i know you're asking specifically about
the rhetoric that we're hearing from
china
but as it relates to
the speakers
the speaker's
travels
it's something that we're just not going
to speak to right now that's a
hypothetical
hypothetical the the the wheels up on
the the
second in line to the presidency of the
united states and the white house can't
stand behind her
yeah so listen there's a couple things
going on here with the press secretary
first i understand that you don't want
to confirm the speaker of the house's
travel until she's wheels down in taiwan
totally get that i've been there a
million times the problem is that
president biden already let the cat out
of the bag so to speak whenever he
answered the question and started
talking about it uh publicly and and
said well you know the u.s military
doesn't want her to go it was very
irresponsible abide in to talk about it
publicly to even answer the question and
he sort of put beijing in a corner by
doing that
secondly though
even if you can't talk about the trip in
and of itself you have to address this
this editor of the global times by the
way he's very boisterous i think he used
to say the worst things about me when i
was state department spokesperson i used
to laugh at them by the way and print
them out and put them on the wall maybe
they'll be in my book one day if i have
time to write it like gordon uh but the
point is whenever you are asked to
specifically address the threat to the
life of the speaker of the house uh you
know third in line to the presidency
what do you do you have to stand up
strong and equivocally and say you know
absolutely you will not threaten the
lives of top u.s officials and they
couldn't say that from the white house i
don't know if it was the incompetence of
the press secretary or just the weak
position of the biden white house in
general
gordon i they were surprised actually
you gave a much stronger answer to what
i was asking about than i thought there
is a lot of dispute about what happened
with this biden uh president g call why
not just release the transcript and and
put it all to bed the white house
doesn't want to do that though do they
no they don't because it would show that
xi jinping took biden to the cleaners
and you know this has been for the four
previous calls we have seen afterwards
that the chinese have gotten the better
of us each and every time you know in
this phone call according to the chinese
foreign ministry xi jinping threatened
the life of president biden you know the
president should have just hung up the
phone when he heard that threat on his
life i mean this is this is wrong and
what we're doing is we're encouraging
the chinese to make more and more
threats and that's unfortunately the way
this administration thinks it should
should conduct diplomacy
morgan i've only got 20 seconds or so
but the projection of strength has never
been president biden's uh strong suit
has it
no and it's dangerous for america it's
dangerous for the world you know we are
really entering a new era a new time
china wants the world to know it's
puffing up its feathers right they want
to the world to know and think of them
as a superpower they want to be treated
with the respect of a superpower
and we're going to have to get serious
about the threat because they are
serious about projecting their own power
now
morgan and gordon thank you so much for
joining us tonight we really do
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else